the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so like I told you guys Friday
marked the end of the hardest part of
the course and monday marked the end of
the hardest pset so because the rest of
your classes are going full-throttle
this one's gonna wind down a little bit
so today I'd say sit back relax and
enjoy a nuclear catastrophe because we
are going to explain what happened at
Chernobyl now that you've got the
physics and intuitive background to
understand the actual sequence of events
to kick it off I want to show you guys
some actual footage of the Chernobyl
reactor as it was burning so this is the
part that most folks know about
this is footage taken from a helicopter
from folks that were either surveying or
dropping materials on to the reactor
that was probably a bad idea
old where the smoke is we'll get into
what the smoke was
so that red stuff right there that's
actually glowing graphite amongst other
materials from the graphite fire that
resulted from the RBMK reactor burning
after the Chernobyl accident caused by
both flaws in the physical design of the
RBMK reactor an absolute operator
stupidity and neglect of any sort of
safety systems or safety culture we're
lucky to live here in the US where our
worst accident at Three Mile Island was
not actually really that much of an
accident there was a partial meltdown
there was not that much of a release of
radionuclides
into the atmosphere because we do things
like build containments on our reactors
if you think of what a typical reactor
looks like like if you consider the MIT
reactor as a scaled-down version of a
normal reactor all right let's say a
commercial power reactor you've got the
core here you've got a bunch of
shielding around it and you've got a
dome that's rather thick that comprises
the containment that would be the core
this would be some shielding so this is
what you find in US and most other
reactors for the RBMK reactors there was
no containment because it was thought
that nothing could happen and boy were
they wrong so I want to walk you guys
through a chronology of what actually
happened at the Chernobyl reactor which
you guys can read on the NEA or Nuclear
Energy Agency website the same place
that you find Janis and we're going to
refer to a lot of the Janus
cross-sections to explain why these
sorts of events happened so the whole
point of what happened at Chernobyl was
it was desired to see if you could use
the spinning down turbine after you shut
down the reactor to power the emergency
systems at the reactor this would be
following something what's called a loss
of off-site power if the off-site power
of the grid was disconnected from the
react
the reactor automatically shuts down but
the turbine like I showed you a couple
weeks ago is this enormous spinning Hulk
of metal and machinery that coasts down
over a long period of let's say hours
and as it's spinning the generator coils
are still spinning and still producing
electricity or they could be so it was
desired to find out can we use the
spinning down turbine to power the
emergency equipment if we lose off-site
power so they had to simulate this event
so what they actually decided to do is
Coast down the reactor to a moderate
power level or very low power and see
what comes out of the turbine itself
we're out of the generator rather now
there were a lot of flaws in the RBMK
design and I'd like to bring it up here
so we can talk about what it looks like
and what was wrong with it
so the RBMK is unlike any of the United
States light water reactors that you may
have seen before many of the components
are the same there's still light water
reactor coolant loop where a water flows
around fuel rods goes into a steam
separator better known as a big heat
exchanger and the steam drives a turbine
which produces energy and then this
coolant pump keeps it going and then the
water circulates what makes it different
though is that each of these fuel rods
was inside its own pressure tube so the
coolant was pressurized and out here
this stuff right here was the moderator
composed of graphite
unlike light water reactors in the u.s.
the coolant was not the only moderator
in the reactor graphite also existed
which meant that if the water went away
which would normally shut down a light
water reactor from lack of moderation
graphite was still there to slow the
neutrons down into the high vision
cross-section area and I'd like to pull
up Janis and show you what I mean with
the uranium cross-section so let's go
again to uranium-235 and pull up its
fission cross-section Z Fidan
can make it a little thicker - so again
the goal of the moderator is to take
neutrons from high energies like one to
ten MeV where the fission cross-section
is relatively low and slow them down
into this region where fission is let's
say a thousand times more likely and in
a light water reactor in the US if the
coolant goes away so does the moderation
and there's nothing left to slow those
neutrons down to make fission more
likely in the RBMK that's not the case
the graphite is still there the graphite
is cooled by a helium nitrogen mixture
because the neutron interactions in the
graphite that's slowing down we've
always talked about what happens from
the point of view of the neutron but
what about the point of view of the
other material any energy lost by the
neutrons is gained by the moderating
material so the graphite gets really hot
and you have to flow some non oxygen
containing gas mixture like helium and
nitrogen which is pretty inert to keep
that graphite cool and in in between the
graphite moderator where control rods
about 200 of them or so 30 of which were
required to be down in the reactor at
any given time in order to control power
and that was a design rule that was
broken during the actual experiment and
then on top of here on top of this
biological shield you could walk on top
of it so those the tops of those
pressure tubes despite being about 350
kilo chunks of concrete you could walk
on top of them that's pretty cool kind
of scary - so what happened in
chronological order was around midnight
the decision was made to undergo this
test and start spinning down the turbine
but the grid operator came back and said
no you can't just cut the reactor power
to nothing you have to maintain at a
rather high power for a while about 500
megawatts Electric or half the rated
power of the reactor and what that had
the effect of doing is continuing to
create fission products including xenon
135 we haven't mentioned this one yet
you'll talk about it quite a lot in 22
Oh five in Neutron physics black shirt
really shows chalk well okay what
xenon-135 does is it just sits there
it's a noble gas it has a half-life of a
few days so it decays on the slow side
for you know fission prices and products
go but it also absorbs lots and lots and
lots of neutrons let's see if I could
find which one is the xenon one there we
go
so here I've plotted the total
cross-section for a xenon 135 and the
absorption cross-section and notice how
for low energies pretty much the entire
cross-section of xenon is made up of
absorption did you guys in your homework
see anything that reached about 10
million barns no xenon 135 is one of the
best Neutron absorbers there is and
reactors produce it constantly so as
they're operating you're build-up xenon
135 that you have to account for in your
Sigma absorption cross-section because
like you guys saw in the homework if you
want to write what's the Sigma
absorption cross section of the reactor
it's the sum of every single isotope in
the reactor of its number density times
its absorption cross section and so that
would include everything for water and
let's say the uranium and the xenon that
you're building up when the reactor
starts up the number density of xenon is
zero because you don't have any anything
to have produced it when you start
operating you'll reach the xenon
equilibrium level where it will build to
a certain level that will counteract the
reactivity of the reactor and in your K
effective expression where its sources
over absorption plus leakage this has
the effect of rise at raising Sigma
absorption and lowering K effective the
trick is it doesn't last for very long
it both decays with a half-life of about
five days and when you try and raise the
reactor power you will also start to
burn it out so if you're operating at a
fairly low power level you'll both be
decaying and burning xenon without
really knowing what's going
and that's exactly what happened here so
an hour or so later let me pull up the
chronology again a little more than an
hour later so the reactor power
stabilized at something like 30
megawatts and they were like what is
going on why is the reactor power so low
we need to increase the reactor power so
what did they do couple things one was
remove all but six or seven of the
control rods going way outside the spec
of the design because 30 were needed to
actually maintain the reactor at a
stable power all the while the xenon
that had been building up is still there
keeping the reactor from going critical
it's what was the main reason that the
reactor didn't even have very much power
but it was also burning out at the same
time so all the while let's say if we
were to show a graph of two things time
xenon inventory and as a solid line and
let's say control rod worth as a dotted
line the xenon inventory at full power
would have been at some level and then
it would start to decay and burn out
well at the same time the control rod
worth as you remove control rods from
the reactor every time you remove one
you lose some control rod worth would
continue to diminish leading to the
point where bad stuff is gonna happen
you make sure I didn't lose my place so
at any rate as they started pulling the
control rods out a couple of interesting
quirks happened in terms of feedback so
let's look back at this design like any
reactor this reactor had what's called a
negative fuel temperature coefficient
what that means is that and you heat up
the fuel two things happen one the
cross-section for anything absorption or
fission would go up but the number
density would also go down as the atoms
physically spaced out in the fuel their
number density would go down lowering
the macroscopic cross section for
fission and that's arguably a good thing
the problem is at below about 20% power
the reactor had what's called a positive
void coefficient
which meant that if you boil the coolant
you increase the reactor power because
the other thing that I think I mentioned
this once and you calculated in the
homework the absorption cross section of
hydrogen is not zero it's small but
fairly significant let's actually take a
look at it because we can always see
this in Janus go back down to hydrogen
hydrogen one we look at the absorption
cross section and of course it started
us with a linear scale
let's go logarithmic ah okay so at low
energy is that you know ten to the minus
eight to ten to the minus seven it's
around a barn not super high but
absolutely not negligible which meant
that part of the normal functionality
the RBMK depending on depended on the
absorption of the water to help absorb
some of those neutrons with those
neutrons gone I'm sorry with those
without water gone there was less
absorption but there was still a ton of
moderation in this graphite moderator so
they still could get slow but then
there'd be more of them and that would
cause the power to increase and then
that caused more of the water the
coolant to boil which would cause less
absorption which would cause the power
to increase yeah Charlie they did not
remove the water from the reactor
however as the power started to rise
some of the water started to boil and so
you can still have let's say steam
flowing through and still remove some of
the heat however you don't have that
denser water to act as an absorber and
that's what really undid this reactor in
addition they decided to disable the EE
CCS or the emergency core cooling system
which are just not supposed to do so
they shut down a bunch of these systems
to see if you could power the other ones
from the spinning down turbine and then
as they notice that the reactor was
getting less and less stable they had
almost all the rods out some of these
pressure tubes started to bump and jump
these 350 kilogram pressure tube caps
just rattling I mean imagine something
that weighs you know 900 pounds or so
rattling around and there's a few
hundred of them so there was someone in
the control room that said the caps are
rattling what the heck didn't quite make
it down the spiral staircase because
about 10 seconds later everything went
wrong and so I want to pull up this
actual timeline so you can see it splits
from minutes to seconds because the
speed at which this stuff started to go
wrong was pretty striking so for example
the control rods raised at 119 in the
morning two minutes later when the power
starts to become unstable the caps on
the fuel channels which again are like
350 kilogram
blocks start jumping in their sockets
and a lot of that was to go back to the
RBMK reactor as the coolant started to
boil here well that boiling force
actually creates huge pressure
instabilities which would cause the
pressure tubes to jump up and down
eventually rupturing almost every single
one of them with enough force to shoot
these 350 kilo caps and still what did
that what do they say I like the
language that they used jumping in their
sockets so 50 seconds later pressure
fails in the steam drums which means
there's been some sort of containment
leak so all the while the coolant was
boiling the absorption was going down
the power was going up repeat repeat
repeat and the power jumped to about a
hundred times the rated power in
something like four seconds so it was
normally a thousand megawatt electric
reactor which is about 3,200 megawatts
thermal it was producing nearly half a
terawatt of thermal power for a very
short amount of time until it exploded
now the eccentricity a lot of folks call
Chernobyl and nuclear explosion that's
actually a misnomer a nuclear explosion
would be a nuclear weapon something set
off by an enormous chain reaction
principally heated by fission or fusion
that's not actually what happened at
Chernobyl nor at Fukushima nor was that
the worry at Three Mile Island not to
say it wasn't a horror
whole thing but it wasn't an actual
nuclear explosion at first what happened
was a pressure explosion so there was an
enormous release of steam as the power
built up to a hundred times normal
operating power the steam force was so
large that it actually blew the reactor
lid up off of the thing and I think I
have a picture of that somewhere here -
it should be further down yeah to give
you a little sense of scale the reactor
cover which weighed about a thousand
tons launched into the air and landed
above the reactor sending most of the
reactor components up to a kilometer up
in the air four seconds later that was
followed by a hydrogen explosion when we
get back down to that chronology so yeah
at one twenty three and forty seconds in
the morning oh yeah so I should mention
why this happened an emergency insertion
of all the control rods the last part
that this diagram doesn't mention is
these control rods and I'll draw this up
here were tipped with about six inches
of graphite so if these were to graphite
channels let's say these are carbon and
this is your control rod the goal was to
get this control rod all the way into
the reactor one part they didn't mention
was they were tipped with about six
inches of graphite which only functions
as additional moderator graphite is one
of the lowest absorbing materials in the
periodic table second I think only two
oxygen and if we pull up Graphite's
cross-sections I've plotted here the
total cross-section the elastic
scattering cross-section and down here
in the 0.001 bar and level is the
absorption cross-section about a
thousand times lower than water so
you're shoving more material in the
reactor that slows down neutrons even
more bringing them into the high fishing
region without absorbing anything and
they jammed about halfway down about two
and a half feet down leaving the extra
graphite right in the center of the core
where it could do the most damage and it
didn't take
much time yeah yep
they took seven to ten seconds I'm not
sure I don't know whether lowering
control rods into something that was
undergoing steam explosions would have
actually helped to me by this point it
was all over whether or not you know so
the extra the extra absolute is that the
extra moderator that was dumped in was
the last kick in the pants this thing
needed to go absolutely insane and if we
go back to the time line on the second
level control rods inserted at 123 and
40 seconds explosion four seconds later
ah two 120 times full power getting
towards a Tara water so one second later
the thousand ton lid launches off from
the first explosion very shortly after
that second explosion and that happened
because of this reaction well any just
about anything corroding with water will
make pretty much anything oxide plus
hydrogen the same chemical explosion
that was the undoing of Fukushima and
was the worry at Three Mile Island that
there was a hydrogen bubble building
because of corrosion reactions with
whatever happened to be in the core this
happens with the zirconium pretty
vigorously but it happens with other
materials too if you oxidize something
with water you leave behind the hydrogen
and the hydrogen in a very wide range of
concentrations in the air is explosive
we're actually not allowed to use
hydrogen at above 4% in any of the labs
here because that reaches the
flammability or explosive limit so we
were doing some from my PhD we were
doing these experiments corroding
materials in liquid lead and we wanted
to dump in pure hydrogen to see what
happens when there's no oxygen and we
were told absolutely not we had to drill
a hole in the side of the wall so that
the hydrogen would vent outside and do
some calculations to show if the entire
bottle of hydrogen emptied into the lab
at once which it could do if the cap of
the bottle breaks off it would not reach
for
and concentration so hydrogen explosions
are pretty powerful things have you guys
ever seen people making water from
scratch mix hydrogen and oxygen in a
bottle and light a match we've got a
video of it circulating somewhere around
here because for our TC for the reactor
technology course I do this in front of
a bunch of CEOs watch them jump out of
their chairs to teach basic chemical
reactions but it's pretty loud enough
about enough hydrogen and oxygen to just
fill this cup or fill a half liter water
bottle makes a bang that gets your ears
ringing not quite bleeding but close
enough so that's what happened here
except on a much more massive scale so
there was a steam explosion followed
seconds later by a hydrogen explosion
from hydrogen liberated from the
corrosion reaction of everything with
the water that was already there and
that's when this happened
so that's smoke right there from the
graphite fire it's not normal smoke
[Music]
[Music]
this actually provides a perfect conduit
to transition from the second to the
third parts of this course a lot of you
have been waiting to find out what are
the units of dose and what are the
biological and chemical effects of
radiation well this is where you get
them from Neutron physics you can
understand why Chernobyl went wrong with
honestly you've just been doing this for
three or four weeks but with your
knowledge of cross-sections reactor
feedback in criticality you can start to
understand why Chernobyl was flawed in
this design and what we're gonna teach
you in the rest of the course is what
happens next
what happens when radionuclides are
absorbed by animals of the human body
and what was the main fallout let's say
in the in the colloquial sense and the
actual sense from the Chernobyl reactor
let's look a bit what they did next
though
the Socratic universe is productivity in
Israel you see them the chasm partial
pressure just a touch
against it'll give honest even yet
shooter but the key is Wharram the
limited sense of discovery solution is
on education travel reactor but what a
treat Tom Cruise okay McCarter three
balls two situations test or push misty
got serigraphy
[Music]
- geraniums fear that's not quite true
that actually did happen
I think that pretty much summarizes the
state of things now the they built a
sarcophagus around this reactor a
gigantic tomb which according to some
reports is not that structurally sound
and is in danger of partial collapse so
yeah more difficult efforts are ahead
but let's now talk about what happened
next I'm gonna jump to the very end of
this the actual way that the accident
was noticed was the spread of the
radioactive cloud to not so close by
Sweden so it was noticed that folks
entering a reactor in Sweden had
contaminants on them which they thought
was coming from their own reactor good
first assumption when it was determined
that nothing was amiss at the reactor in
Sweden folks started to analyze wind
patterns and find out what happened and
then it was clear that the USSR had
tried to cover up the Chernobyl accident
but you can't cover up fallout and it
eventually spread pretty wide covering
most of Europe Russia and surprisingly
not Spain lucky them for the wind
patterns that that day or those few days
so what happened is a few days after the
actual accident a graphite fire started
to break out because graphite when
exposed to air well you can do the
chemistry add graphite plus oxygen you
start making carbon dioxide so graphite
burns when it's hot and as you could see
from the video where is that nice still
of burning graphite yeah that graphite
was pretty hot so a lot of that smoke
included burning graphite and a lot of
the materials from the reactor itself
now when you build up fission products
in a reactor and they get volatilized
like this the ones that tend to get out
first would be things like the noble
gases so the whole xenon inventory of
the reactor was released it's estimated
about a hundred percent I can actually
pull up those figures when we talk about
how much of which radionuclide was
released that's also a typo if somebody
wants to call in there's no 33
isotope of xenon it's supposed to be 133
that would be interesting some wants to
call it and say the NEA is got a mistake
so a hundred percent of the inventory
released that should be pretty obvious
because it's a noble gas and it just
kind of floats away the real dangers
though came from iodine-131
about 50% of a 3x uh Becquerel activity
so we're talking like mega Curie's that
it might be Giga can't do that math in
my head a lot a lot of radiation and the
problem with that is iodine behaves just
like any other halogen it forms salts
it's rather volatile when you guys
played with iodine before no one does
you know you have okay what happens with
it play with it
okay I'll happen to have extensive
practice playing with iodine in my home
because I did all the stuff you're not
supposed to do as a kid and it build
your own chemistry step things that
somehow you know leak out of your local
high school somehow iodine is pretty
neat yeah it happens sometimes if you
put iodine in your hand it actually
sublimes the heat from your hand is
enough to directly go from solid to
vapor and so the iodine was also quite
volatile some of it may have been in the
form of other compounds some of it may
have been elemental probably not likely
but there was certainly some iodine
vapor and about half of that was
released the problem is then it
condenses out and falls on anything
green anything with surface area so the
biggest danger to the folks living
nearby was from eating leafy vegetables
because the loads that leaves got loss
of surface area iodine deposits on them
and it's intensely radioactive for a
month or so or depositing on the grass
that cows eat which led to the problem
of radioactive milk and so that's why
milk in the Soviet Union was banned for
such a long time because this was one of
the major sources of iodine
contamination the other one which were
worrying about now from Fukushima as
well is cesium which has similar
chemistry to sodium and potassium again
a rather salty compound or rather salty
element but it's got a half-life of
thirty years and if we look it up in the
table of nuclides you'll see what it
actually releases oh good it's back
online anyone else noticed this broken a
couple days ago yeah well luckily
Brookhaven National Lab has a good
version up to but let's grab cesium yeah
there's plenty out there cesium 137 beta
decays to barium but also gives off
gamma rays and most of the decays end up
giving off one of those gamma rays let's
say a 660 ke V gamma ray
so it's both a beta and a gamma emitter
now which of those types of radiation do
you think is more damaging to biological
organisms the beta or the gamma
you say the Gamo why do you say so it
does but if cesium is better known as
yes that's right so did I get to tell
you guys this question the for cookies
question yeah you eat the gamma cookie
because most gammas that are emitted by
the cookie simply leave you and I
radiate your friend which is going to be
the topic of pset number eight you'll
see that's why you guys are getting your
whole body counts speaking of who's
who's gotten their whole body counts at
EHS awesome so that's almost everybody
you will need that data for problem set
eight so do schedule it soon preferably
before Thanksgiving so that you'll be
able to take a look at it does anyone
found anything interesting in your
spectra good glad to hear that but you
do see a potassium peak that you can it
probably integrate and do some problems
with right yeah because you will okay
anyway yeah it's the betas that's the
real killer the gammas are gonna leave
the cesium enter your body and most
likely come out the other side because
the mass attenuation coefficient of six
what is it water for a 660 ke V gammas
let's find that table three let's say
you're made mostly of water water liquid
that's pretty much humans 660 K V is
right about here leading to about 0.1
centimeter squared per gram and with a
density of one gram that's a pretty low
attenuation of gammas so this chart
actually shows why most of the cesium
gammas that would be produced from
ingestion just get right out but it's
the betas that have an awfully short
range anyone remember the formula for
range in general cause it's gonna come
back up in our discussion of dose and
biological effects
integral love yup of stopping power to
the negative one and that stopping power
is this simple formula squared a simple
little formula which I'm not gonna
expect you guys to memorize so don't
worry about it but if you integrate this
you find out that the range of electrons
even one of e electrons and water is not
very high so most of them are stopped
near or by the cells that absorb them
doing quite a bit of damage the DNA
which is eventually what causes
mutagenic effects cancer cell death what
we're going to talk about for the whole
third part of the course there's also a
worry about which organs actually absorb
these radionuclides and iodine in
particular is preferentially absorbed by
the thyroid so when we started looking
at the amount of radioactive substances
released remember they said okay at
around 26th of April or the second of
May or so the release was stopped not
according to our data that's when the
graphite fire picked up again in
addition the core of Chernobyl which had
undergone a mostly total meltdown was
sitting in a pool on top of this
concrete pad so let's just call this
liquid stuff for the actual word that we
use in parlance is called corium it's
our tongue-in-cheek word for every
element mixed together in a hot
radioactive soup it's first of all it
started to redistribute reacting with
any water that was present flashing it
to steam and the steam caused additional
dispersion of radionuclides and
eventually it borrowed its way through
and into the ground releasing more you
know it's it's a it's the worst nuclear
thing that's ever happened in the
history of nuclear things quite a mess
and luckily it did sort of taper off
after this but let's now look into what
happens next and this is the nice intro
to the third part of the course iodine
is is preferentially up taken by the
thyroid gland somewhere right about here
so is anyone ever heard of the idea of
taking iodine tablets in the case of a
nuclear disaster anyone have any idea
why if you saturate your thyroid with
iodine then if you ingest radioactive
iodine it's less likely to be
permanently up taken by the thyroid so
this actually provided some statistics
on the probability of getting siren
cancer from radioactive iodine ingestion
luckily the statistics were quite poor
which means that not many people were
exposed it was somewhere around 1300 or
so not like millions yeah 1300 people
total but what I want to jump to is the
dose versus risk curve and this is gonna
be lie all of our discussion about the
biological long-term effects of
radioactivity what's the most striking
thing you see as part of this curve
that's that's right that's the first
thing I saw there are six different
models for how dose and increased risk
of cancer proceeds and they all fall
within almost all the error bars of
these measurements I say again thank God
that the error bars are so high because
that means that the sample size was so
low so when folks say we don't really
know how much radioactivity causes how
much cancer they're right because
luckily we don't have enough data from
people being exposed to know that really
really well so some folks say we should
be cautious I kind of agree with them
some folks say the jury's still out I
also agree with them but you can start
to estimate these sorts of things by
knowing how much radiation energy was
absorbed and to what organ so I think
the only technical thing I want to go
over today is the different units of
dose because as you start to read things
in the reading which I recommend you do
if you haven't been doing
you're going to encounter a lot of
different units of radiation dose
ranging from things like the roentgen
which responds to a number of
ionizations you won't usually see this
one given in sort of biological parlance
because it's the number of ionizations
detected by some sort of gaseous
ionization detector
so the dosimeter is that you all put on
the did you guys all bring these uh
these like brass pen dosimeter xin to
the reactor did anyone look through them
to see what the unit of dose was it's
gonna be in renkins because that's
directly correlated to the number of
ionizations that that dosimeter has
experienced you'll also see four dose
units two of which are just factors of
100 away from each other there's what's
called the rad and the grey and there's
what's called the rim and the sievert
you'll see these approximated as gray
you'll see these as are and these are
just usually written as rim so a rad is
simple let's see 100 rads is the same as
one gray and 100 rim is the same as one
sievert and for gamma for the case of
gamma radiation these units are actually
equal I particularly like this set of
units because this is the kind of si of
radiation units because it comes
directly from measurable calculated
quantities like the grey for example the
actual unit of grey is joules absorbed
per kilogram of absorber it's a pretty
simple unit to understand if you know
how many radioactive particles or gammas
or whatever that you have absorbed you
can multiply that number by their energy
divided by the mass of the organ
absorbing them and you get its dose in
grey sievert is gray times some quality
factor for the radiation
times some quality factor for the
specific type of tissue what this says
is that some types of radiation are more
effective at causing damage than others
and some organs are more susceptible to
radiation damage than others does anyone
happen to know some of the organs that
are most susceptible to radiation damage
Souths tissues like what because there's
lots of those stomach lining yep
yeah huh lungs yep what else die roid
yep there there is definitely one for
thyroid bone marrow what other ones you
know brain actually not so much the eyes
and where else do you find rapidly
dividing cells in your body skin yep
the dermis I don't know about the liver
I would assume so yeah it's a pretty
active organ but when folks are worried
about birth defects reproductive organs
the link here that for some reason is
not said in the reading and I've never
figured out why is the more often a cell
is dividing the more susceptible it is
to gaining cancer risk because every
cell division is a copy of its DNA and
any time that radiation goes in and
damages or changes that DNA by either
causing what's called a thymine bridge
where two timing bases get linked
together or damaging the structure in
some other way that gene is then
replicated and the faster they're
replicating the more likely cancer is
going to become apparent
I guess this brings up a question when
does a rapidly dividing cell become
cancer is it division number one or is
it when you notice it because I'll leave
that question to the biologists but if
you notice in the reading you'll see a
bunch of different tissue equivalency
factors and you'll just see them
tabulated and say there they are
memorize them I want you to try and
think of the pattern between them
the tissues that basically don't matter
like the non mero part of the bone dead
skin cells muscles things that basically
aren't listed that much they're not
dividing very fast but anywhere where
you find stem cells the lining of your
intestine your lungs would undergo a lot
of environmental damage need to be
replenished gonads durum skin what was
the other one that we said eyes these
are places that are either sensitive
tissues or their rapidly dividing and so
the sievert is kind of in a unit of
increased equivalent risk so that if you
were to absorb one gray of gamma-rays
versus one gray of alphas you'd be about
twenty times more likely to incur cancer
from the alphas than the gammas because
the amount of localized damage that they
do to cells and we'll be doing all this
in detail pretty soon and then for
tissue equivalency factor if you absorb
one gray in your whole body which means
one Joule per kilogram of average body
mass versus one gray directly to the
lining of your intestines by let's say
drinking polonium laced tea like
happened to a poor Rick was it current
or ex-kgb guy one of the Russian fellas
no it's the KGB guys that poisoned him
right yeah do you guys remember back in
2010 or so there was a Russian see a
journalist ex-kgb so the current KGB
somehow got into London and slipped
polonium into his tea at a Japanese
restaurant
ah really what was his name
let's see then um poisoning did he
actually die poisoning of Alexander
litter Vanko he's not doing too well
illness poisoning death and last
statement at the hospital in London so
yeah well interesting that probably has
something to do with it yeah well uh
we're not gonna comment on the politics
but the the radiation effect worked
clearly unfortunately so polonium is an
alpha emitter and that caused a massive
dose of alphas to his entire
gastrointestinal tract and that caused a
whole lot of damage to those cells no
time for cancer it actually killed off a
lot of those stem cells and the way that
radiation poisoning would work is that
if you kill off the stem cells the villi
in your intestine die which are
responsible for absorbing nutrition
you can't uptake nutrition you basically
starve doesn't matter what you eat it's
messed up yeah
that's a really bad way to go it's
called gastrointestinal syndrome and
we'll be talking about the progressive
effects of acute radiation exposure
where you have immediate effects mostly
relating to the death of some organ that
is responsible for either cell division
to keep you alive or in extreme cases
your neurological system and nerve
function just stops at the highest
levels of dose and that corresponds to
doses of around four to six gray four to
six joules per kilogram of villi or body
mass will kill you pretty quickly with
very little chance of survival as what
happened here and so this was the
problem with all the folks living around
and near Chernobyl and Krane and Belarus
and everywhere was the contamination was
pretty extensive about 4,000 people are
estimated to have died or contracted
cancer from this I can't believe how low
that number is but it's still 4,000
people that had never happened - and
effects were felt far away and towns
like Kamel and I can't read that one
because there's not enough pixels
because of the way that let's say rain
water whist or let's say the vapor cloud
from the reactor was whisked the way
rain water caused it to fall on certain
places which still to this day can have
a really large contamination area and
this brings me a little bit into what
should we be worried about from
Fukushima a whole lot less than
Chernobyl and the reason why is
Fukushima did undergo a hydrogen
explosion and did and still continues to
release cesium 137 into the ocean
luckily for us the ocean is big and
except for fish caught right near around
Fukushima
even though concentrations can be
measured at hundreds to thousands of
times normal concentrations they can
still be hundreds to thousands of times
lower than the safe consumption so a lot
of the problems you see in the news
today I'm not going to call them lies
but I'm going to call them half-truths
folks will show the radiation plume of
cesium 137 escaping from Fukushima and
that's true there is radiation escaping
the question is is it high enough to
cause a noticeable increase risk of
that's the question that reporters
should be asking themselves when they
only tell the half of the story that
gets them viewers and they don't tell
the half of the story to complete the
story and tell you should you be afraid
or not because unfortunately fear brings
viewers this is the problem that I'm
happy to go on camera saying this this
is the problem with the media today is
with a half-truth and with a half story
you can sin cite real panic over
non-physical issues that may not
actually exist and so it's important
that the media tell the whole story yes
it's true that Fukushima is leasing
releasing cesium 137 how much though is
the question that people and the media
should be asking themselves and in the
rest of this course we're gonna answer
the question how much is too much so I'm
gonna stop here since it's two of five
of and ask you guys if you have any
questions on the whole second part of
the course or what happened in Chernobyl
yeah yep the quality phat well there's
two quality factors there's the quality
factor for radiation which will tell you
how much let's say how much more cell
damage a given amount of a given type of
radiation of the same energy will
deposit into a cell and the tissue
equivalency factor tells you well what's
the added risk of some sort of defect
leading to cell death or cancer or some
other defect from that radiation
absorption so to me the tissue
equivalency factor is roughly but not
completely approximated by the cell
division rate and the radiation quality
factor is going to be quite proportional
to the stopping power you'll see a term
called the linear energy transfer or le
T this is the stopping power unit used
in the biology community it's stopping
power and luckily the Turner reading
actually says it's somewhere buried in a
paragraph le T is stopping power so if
you start plotting these two together
you might find some striking
similarities I saw two other questions
up here yeah
let's answer that with numbers so most
of the half-lives were on the range of
days two hours but still
cesium-137 with a half-life of 30 years
released a third of an XML that's one of
the major sources of contamination still
out there in addition if we scroll down
a little more there was quite a bit of
plutonium inventory with a half-life of
24,000 years so on on Friday we're gonna
have Jake Hekla come in and give his
chernobyl travelogue because one of our
seniors has actually been to Chernobyl
and his boots were so contaminated with
Pullo with plutonium that he can never
use them again they got to stay wrapped
up in plastic so some of these things
last tens of thousands of years and even
though there weren't a lot of peda beck
urls of plutonium released their alpha
emitters and they're extremely dangerous
when ingested so greens and things that
uptake radionuclides from the soil like
moss and mushrooms are totally off
limits in a large range of this area you
will find a video online if you look of
a mayor from a nearby town saying oh
they're perfectly safe to eat look I eat
them right here and I just say read the
comments for what people have to say
about that not too smart yeah
the so so the sarcophagus around the
reactors got to be shored up to make
sure that nothing else gets out because
most of the reactor is still there and
let's say rainwater comes in and starts
washing away more stuff into the ground
or whatever we don't want that to happen
soil replacement and disposal as nuclear
waste is still going on removal of any
moss like in mushrooms or anything with
a sort of radiation exposure has got to
keep going
but this the area that it covers is
enormous
I don't know if we're ever gonna get rid
of all of it the question is how much do
we have to get rid of to lower our risk
of cancer in the area to an acceptable
rate there will likely be parts of this
that are inaccessible for thousands to
tens of thousands of years unless we
hopefully get smarter about how to
contain and dispose of this kind of
stuff we're not there yet so right now
the methods are kind of simple get rid
of the soil fence off the area some
folks have been returning and they do
get compensation and free medical visits
because the background levels there are
elevated but not that high so folks have
started to move back to some of these
areas but there's a lot that are still
off-limits
any other questions yeah
yeah the number of deaths from the
atomic bombs way outweighed the number
of deaths that will ever happen from
Chernobyl oh not that much of an issue
there wasn't that much material that nah
there wasn't that much nuclear material
in an atomic bomb what did you guys get
for the radius of the critical sphere of
plutonium centimeters yeah doesn't take
a lot it takes you know 10 20 kilos to
make a weapon now we're talking about
tons or thousands of tons of material
released so an atomic weapon doesn't
kill by radiation it kills by pressure
wave the heat wave the fallout is not as
much of a concern and we'll actually be
looking at the data from Hiroshima and
Nagasaki survivors to see who got what
dose what increased cancer risk did they
get and is this is the idea that every
little bit of radiation is a bad thing
actually true the answer is you can't
say yes or no no one can say yes or no
because we don't have good enough data
the error bars support either conclusion
so I'm not going to go on record and say
a little bit of radiations okay they
does not out yet
hopefully I never will be any other
questions all right I'll see you guys on
Thursday
you